memory is the cheekiest most tenacious
little boy that I think I've ever met
when Lauren's son Henry was born doctors
were unable to diagnose just what was
wrong it was 20 months before a
groundbreaking DNA test found he had
Costello syndrome a rare disease that
makes him susceptible to childhood
cancers it was like a massive weight off
our shoulders as in we finally had an
idea of what Henry's life might look
like and why he behaved the way he did
the unknown is so much worse than the
known so by having that allowed us to
have a better understanding and
acceptance really of what life might be
like for Henry the new fast-track DNA
test which diagnosed Henry was developed
by a team of scientists in Exeter a
single test which looks for genetic
mutations in a child's DNA as part of
this new test DNA samples are taken to
this machine it helps to diagnose from
around 5,000 different rare conditions a
process which used to take 10 days is
now done in 27 hours it's now being
rolled out across the NHS since being
introduced in October 2000 and 1980
babies and children have received the
new tests of those almost half were
given a diagnosis for their rare disease
for the first time up to 700 babies and
children are expected to benefit each
year from the tests which can cut
diagnosis times from weeks to days it's
a huge step because when genetic tests
had started in the NHS about 25 years
ago looking for rare diseases such as
cystic fibrosis we had to set up each
test for each disease so in fact we only
were able to test for the most common of
the rare diseases and today that doesn't
matter you know turn the page good boy a
single quicker test means children
suffering from some of the rarest
diseases could now get a quicker
diagnosis and in turn quicker treatment
Dan Whitehead Sky News in Exeter